[Music]
millions of us watched in Wanderers man
first set foot upon the moon fifty years
ago today and succeeding generations
have shared in the adventure through
film and video but in the era of space
travel
now dawning far more of us are destined
not to be just observers but
participants mark Strassmann has that
story good morning mark good morning
good morning in many ways space in 2019
has become a rich man's obsession
several self-made billionaires have
started space companies and their
competition once again could change the
way we look at the sky and the world we
live on in America's new space age
NASA's human space monopoly is over the
emerging leaders are companies not
countries and anyone anyone with enough
money can become an astronaut people
want to go to space should go to space
because they come back changed to one
release release release Richard Branson
the Virgin brand billionaire launched
his space tourism business in 2004 from
Virgin Galactic space port in New Mexico
six passengers per flight will rocket
more than 62 miles above Earth for the
ultimate selfie Branson is selling space
dreams these people meeting him bought
one six hundred of them have prepaid a
quarter million dollars for the chance
to fly including Mary Ann Barry a 58
year old Floridian all your life you've
watched astronauts do it now it's your
turn yes sir it's my turn and I'm going
they do want to see what the earth looks
like from space I want to have that
overview event
variance but Virgin Galactic has yet to
launch a single paying customer and will
only say it'll happen soon any question
has been more challenging than you would
have expected it's taken is 14 years
space definitely is hard we've had our
tears we've had a joys and but I'll tell
you what the joys have been fantastic
another rocket man and Branson
competitor is Amazon founder Jeff Bezos
Blue Origin his space company hopes to
launch tourists and a reusable vehicle
by year's end but the company has yet to
start selling tickets
Bezos also wants to build the
infrastructure to colonize space one day
starting with a presence on the moon I
think that's entirely believable if you
went back in time 100 years and told
people today that you would be able to
buy a ticket and fly across the world on
a jetliner they would have thought you
were crazy the final liftoff of Atlantis
when the space shuttle program ended in
2011 astronauts had one way to get to
the International Space Station hitch a
ride on the Russian Soyuz NASA wants
American space taxis so it hired two
companies SpaceX and Boeing to become
its space uber and lyft astronaut Chris
Ferguson commanded NASA's final shuttle
mission you know it's just amazing how
real it is all be coming here
he hopes to ride a spaceship again the
Boeing Starliner which he helped design
I am a corporate astronaut and now what
the heck is a corporate astronaut I mean
now we don't know you know there's one
of a kind right now but SpaceX the
vision of Tesla founder Elon Musk has
built reusable rockets and a sleek space
capsule called
crew dragon but like Boeing SpaceX is
two years behind schedule with vague
promises about when it will fly
astronauts there still haven't lost
anyone yet but hopefully we will later
this year and so that would definitely
be the culmination of a long dream for a
lot of people SpaceX is first crew NASA
astronauts Bob Behnken and Doug Hurley
are competitive guys in a new space race
you want to get there before ferger's
absolutely we're gonna you're gonna yeah
no question no and why does that matter
I played a lot of sports competitively
and I have no problem with a little
healthy competition and I think it's
better it makes you better and it makes
him better and it makes both companies
better and in the end who benefits the
country you know we get redundant access
to space redundant space access a
competition between companies and space
barons who own them Rockets flying
tourists that's a giant leap from the
footprints Apollo 11 left behind 50
years ago today the only reason that we
can do the things that we can do today
is because we are in fact standing on
the shoulders of giants so all of those
things that came before are what make it
possible for a small team to go do these
amazing things and these new space
companies and their owners have learned
a few things from the Apollo era success
stories that is space exploration is
demanding it takes time it costs a lot
of money space is hard Elaine
all right mark Strassmann thank you it
really is a lot of money it is a new
kind of space race though a lot of
implications there right right pay to
play you got to have the money would you
go I might I think about you go
perhaps there you go